like variation that
election is of course the source of all
tations in the biological realm but my
view is it's also the source of all
adaptations in the human and cultural
realm including all of the wonderful
inventions and artifacts that we have
produced blind variation and natural
selection is the only process operating
in the ontogeny and the development of
the brain that produces behavior which
is adaptive whether it means you know
scratching an itch or making a cup or a
pen or an Apple computer there's no
design anywhere it's all or when it's -
design it's just not a designer
you see what I think you're doing and in
the way Richard do is you're taking the
folk ideology of design more seriously
than you should look the term Adam means
indivisible in Greek so we should have
full there aren't any atoms there aren't
any Alison no well instead we said turns
out you can divide an atom it was it was
and people find that you know they they
learn to get the initially they five
atoms are invisible now we discover oh
my goodness they're the visible also I
think it's a an easier pedagogical task
to convince people that there's design
without a designer designed without an
intelligent designer that it is to
convincingly design so our objective
should be to change everybody's
conceptual economy while leaving the
tokens that they use in everyday speech
changing the meanings of all the words
because my design stance works exactly
as well on biology as it works on than
the artifact and biology is in my terms
reverse engineering if it's reverse
engineering the biosphere if it's
reverse engineering then there's then
then
the biologists are helping themselves to
design concepts left right and center
and we should just say look there's a
perfectly naturalistic non intelligent
design sense of design that is
everywhere evident in biology and
biologists what Garmin did this is your
half-full half-empty what Darwin did
this showed how to naturalize the
concept of design and and biologically
generated design is not second rate
design it's it's the only kind of design
because I agree about that it is but all
the things that people marvel at when it
comes to thinking about those are things
the the economy the very things of
design enables that I know this is this
is this is the but I think this is a
notice it's not a substantive debate we
all agree about the marvels of the
biosphere I will agree that there's a
naturalistic explanation
the question is should we be afraid that
if we use the word design we're giving a
hostage to the creationists and I hope
that you scientists aren't so concerned
about political correctness and are more
concerned about clarity because I hope
you're out even this layman if you're
clear how not to misconstrue what you're
saying so I would curse that otherwise I
think you might actually be money what
you're saying and that would be nobody
disagrees that's not the discussion the
discussion is does knowledge of the
fundamental laws of physics however you
want to think about the laws of physics
which is a whole different discussion
are there in just empirically adequate
retinal incisions are laws in some more
strong sense or determine whatever it is
are those the necessary and sufficient
conditions to derive in principle
everything else they're the special
sciences do that is the question and it
seems to me that it's much more
complicated and simply a Paula cream
that it's everything is made of
permanence we do agree about that one
so there we get into discussions of what
how do we conceptualize laws or
explanations or both it does come down
to what Don called or referred to
something like a promissory note on the
part of reduction isn't it is you know
there's this idea that well in principle
things are reducible to fundamentally
what the frick what is that principle
exactly I've never heard it spell that
particularly convincingly and then
furthermore the empirical evidence seems
to me to be premature yeah that is you
know if you look at the world that the
way science looks at the world there's
plenty of evidence first in evidence and
scientific evidence of emergent
properties now whether those that
doesn't justify the further metaphysical
conclusion that there are emergent
properties in a strong sense I agree but
it seems to me that at least goes
contrary to the opposite not the
physical conclusion that oh we don't
need a mental properties because clear
there are no business of shipping around
there yes so there is a serious issue
there that science has not handled very
well in fact I believe it was a
physicist is back in the seventies well
Paul Henderson I think it was Paul
phillipan killer who said that that yes
fundamental fundamental physics is very
interesting and it's very it's very
important but in fact has the more
fundamentalist go that way the less they
have to say to the rest of science
including to the rest of physics it
becomes more more irrelevant not because
it is intrinsically relevant because but
because precisely we don't have these
way of cashing out yeah that we can go
and reuse everything
down to the ultimate law of everything
you